Do you plan to make a New Year's
resolution? Will you make more than one?
38% of Americans will make a resolution,
according to a new poll from Ipsos.
Of that group, slightly more plan to make
multiple resolutions, instead of just one.
In the Ipsos poll, of those who plan to
make resolutions, money matters — such as
saving more, buying a house, or paying off
debt — shared top billing with eating
healthier and being more active. Ranking
slightly lower was losing weight, though
getting in shape is consistently popular
in the polls. Helping Americans to keep
those promises, many will wear a Fitbit
or a SmartWatch. 19% in a new Gallup
poll say they currently own one, and 15%
have worn one in the past.
How many people will keep their New Year's
resolutions? 80% in to 2018 YouGov poll
agreed that most people don't
stick to those resolutions.
Whether you make a resolution or not,
AEI wishes you the best in the new year
and good luck keeping those resolutions.
Have you made a New Year's resolution?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.